you made a comment I thought an innocent
comment about kissing yeah that was a
tweet it was it right wait yeah
I just said an alien would probably
think it odd that one of the ways humans
show affection with one another is to
exchange saliva okay then there was it's
not a debatable point that yes I try to
always take a new fresh perspective on
who and what we are yes by wondering
what an alien might think of us right I
thought it was a fair statement as did I
and that led to a I think a GQ article
entitled nerd ruins kissing
I got people mad I've been click baited
a lot lately yeah I'd say a little thing
and then some title would just kind of
exaggerate it in some direction all
right well this next one you should have
known better you know with it title
implies that people didn't know that
that's what they were doing of course
that's what you're doing right so we're
going let's just forget that freak out
you dr. Tyson you have gone on record as
saying the Starship Enterprise would
destroy the Millennium Falcon in a
one-on-one fight and that got obviously
Star Wars fans very upset Star Wars fans
are prickly people I mean you can't say
anything bad no no you can't say
anything correct if it's somehow gets
interpreted as saying something bad okay
well right what I said was but by the
way I don't just jump in and tell people
this
I get asked it I got asked what would
win in a contest between the Starship
Enterprise or the Millennium Falcon and
I said the Starship Enterprise would
wipe its ass with the Millennium Falcon
[Applause]
it would just SWAT it out of the way
yeah
defend that defend that because it's a
larger ship no it's got photon torpedoes
it's got deflector shield it's it would
just it would be some annoyance and it's
like you swat it with a star Star Wars
fans not happy at all not really furious
not happy right and so and I found it
odd and so I wonder whether I should
continue to tweet about movies people
seem to be deeply upset by it yeah when
I'm just revealing something that I
thought they might be interested in yeah
like I said about you know bb-8 who
don't love some bb-8
right my first tweet was bb-8 is way
cuter than r2d2 yeah okay that was fine
so who's gonna argue that alright then
so then I sit by the way bb-8 a smooth
spherical metal ball would skid
uncontrollably on sand man your life is
wrong a touch dub it's tough yeah hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos